Okay so, let's go back and look at our two
questions we were trying to answer. And so far we've
answer the first one, learn over a subset of data,
defined a rule by choosing that subset uniformally randomly and
applying some learning algorithm. And we answered the second question,
which is how do you combine all of those rules
of thumbs by saying, you simply average them. And that
gave us, bagging. So Michael, I'm going to suggest an alternative
to at least the first one. And leave open the
second one for a moment. That's going to get us
to what we're supposed to be talking about today, which
is boosting. So let me throw and idea at you and
you tell me if you think it's a good one.
So rather than choosing uniformly randomly. Over the data, we should
try to take advantage of what we are learning as
we go along, and instead of focusing just kind of randomly,
we should pick the examples that we are not good at.
So what do i mean by that? What i mean by that
is. We should pick a subset based upon whether the examples
in that subset are hard. So what do you think of that?
>> Well, I guess it depends on how we think about hard, right
so it could be that it's hard because some, in some absolute sense right,
or could be that it is hard relative to you know, if we
were to stop now how well we do Yeah, and I mean the latter.
>> Oh. Okay. Alright. Well that I feel like
that makes a lot of sense. I mean, certainly when
I'm you know, trying to learn a new skill,
I'll spend most of my energy on the stuff that
I kind, that I'm kind of on the edge of
being able to do, not the stuff that I've already
mastered. It can be a little dispiriting. But it, but
it I think it, I make faster progress that way.
>> Right and if you, if you go
back to the example that we, we started with, with spam right?
If you come up with a and you see it does a
very good on some of the data, some of the mail examples,
but doesn't do a good job on the other. Why would you spend
your time trying to come up with more rules that do well
on the email messages you already know how to classify? You should
be focusing on the ones you don't know how to classify. And
that's the basic idea here between, the basic idea here behind boosting and
finding the hardest examples.
>> Cool.
>> Okay. So that answers the first one. We're going to
look at the hardest examples, and I'm going to define for
you exactly what that means. I'm going to have to introduce
at least one technical definition. But ,uh, I want to make
certain you got that. And the second one, the combining,
well that's a difficult and sort of complicated thing, but
at a high level, I can explain it pretty easily
by saying we are going to still stick with the mean.
>> Okay.
>> We're voting except this time,this time we
are going to do weighted mean. Now why do we want to do
weighted mean? Well I have to tell you exactly how we are going to
weight it but the basic idea is to avoid the certain situations That
we came across when we looked at the data before, when taking an average
over a bunch of points that are spread out, this gives you an
average or a constant that doesn't give you a lot of information about the
space. So we're going to weight it by something, and it's going to turn
out the way we choose to weight it will be very important. But just
keep in your head for now that we're going to try to
do some sort of weighted average. Some kind of weighted voting. Okay?
>> Sure. One of the things that's scaring me at the moment though is this,
like I have this fear that by focusing
on the hardest questions, and then, and then
sort of mastering those, what's to keep the
learner from starting to kind of lose track of
the ones it has already mastered? Like how,
why does it not thrash back and forth?
>> So that's going to be the trick. Behind the,
the particular way that we do weighting.
>> Okay
>> So I will show you that in a moment, and it's going to require
two slightly technical definitions, that we have
been kind of skirting around, this entire conversation. Okay?
>> Sure.